so you mentioned Quest 3 that's coming
out I've gotten a chance to try that too
that's awesome so the how did you pull
off the mixture so it's not just virtual
reality it's mixed reality yeah I mean I
think it's gonna be it's gonna be the
first mainstream
um mixed reality device I mean obviously
we ship Quest Pro
um last year but it was fifteen hundred
dollars
um and well part of what I'm super proud
of is you know we try to innovate not
just on pushing the state of the art and
delivering new capabilities but making
it so it can be available to everyone
and you know we have this and it's
coming out it's 500 and
um in in some ways I think the mixed
reality is actually better in quest 3
than it was
um than what we're using right now in
quest Pro so I'm really proud of the
team for being able to deliver that kind
of an innovation and get it out but you
know some of this is just
um
software you tune over time and get to
be better part of it is you put together
a product and you figure out what are
the bottlenecks in terms of making it a
good experience so we got the resolution
for the Mixed reality cameras and
sensors to be multiple times better in
quest 3 and we just figured that that
made a very big difference when we saw
the experience that we were able to put
together for Quest Pro
and part of it is also that you know
Qualcomm just came out with their next
Generation chipset for for VR and Mr
that we worked with them on a kind of
custom version of it but that was
available this year for Quest 3 and it
wasn't available in quest Pro so you
know in a way I'm in quest 3 even though
it's not you know the pro product
actually has a stronger chipset in it
than the proline at a third of the cost
so
um so I'm really excited to get this in
people's hands it um it does all the VR
stuff that that Quest 2 and the others
have done too it does it better because
the display is better and and the chip
is is better so you'll get better
graphics
um it's 40 thinner so it's um so just
more comfortable as well but but the Mr
is really the big capability shift and
and part of what's exciting about the
whole Space right now is you know this
isn't like smartphones where you know
companies put out a new smartphone every
year and you can almost barely tell the
difference between that and the the one
the year before it now for this each
time we put out a new headset it has
like a major new capability and and the
big one now
um is is mixed reality the ability to
basically take digital representations
of people or objects and and superimpose
them on the world and basically you know
I mean there's that one version of this
is you're gonna kind of have these
augments or or Holograms and experiences
that you can kind of bring into your
living room or a meeting space or an
office
um another thing that I just think is
going to be a much kind of simpler
innovation
is that there are a lot of VR
experiences today that don't need to be
fully immersive and you know if you're
playing a shooter game or you're doing a
fitness experience and sometimes people
get worried about swinging their arms
around like am I going to hit a lamp or
something you know it's and and who am I
going to run into something
so having that in mixed reality actually
is just a lot more comfortable for
people right you kind of still get the
immersion and the 3D experience
um and you can you can have an
experience that just wouldn't be
possible in the physical world alone but
by being anchored to and be able to see
the physical world around you it's like
it just feels so much safer and more
secure and I think a lot of people are
really going to enjoy that too so yeah
I'm really excited to see how people use
it but yeah Quest 3 coming out um later
this fall
yeah and I got to experience it with
other people sitting around and there's
a lot of furniture and so you get to see
that furniture you get to see those
people and you get to see those people
like
enjoy the Ridiculousness of you like
swinging your arms I mean presumably
their friends of yours even if they make
fun of you they uh there's a lot of love
behind that and that you guys I got to
experience that so that's a really
fundamentally different experience than
just pure VR with like with zombies
coming out of walls and yeah it's like
someone's shooting at you and you hide
behind your real couch in order to duck
the the fire yeah it's incredible how
it's all integrated but also like subtle
stuff like in a room with no windows you
can add Windows to it and you can look
outside as the zombies run towards you
but like it's still nice view outside
you know yeah it's just it's really and
so that's pulled off by having cameras
on the outside of the headset that do
the pass-through I think that technology
is incredible to do that oh yeah headset
yeah it's not just the cameras you
basically need to you need multiple
cameras to capture the different angles
and and sort of the three-dimensional
space and then it's a pretty complex
compute problem an AI problem to map
that to your perspective right because
the cameras aren't exactly where your
eyes are because no two people's eyes
are you're not going to be in exactly
the same place you kind of need to to
get that to to to line up
um and then do that basically in real
time and then generate something that
looks that kind of feels natural
um and then
superimpose whatever digital objects you
want to put there so it's yeah it's a
very interesting technical Challenge and
um and we'll continue tuning this for
for the years to come as well but uh but
I'm pretty excited to to get this out
because I think quest 3 is going to be
the first device like this with that
millions of people are going to get
that's mixed reality and it's only when
you have millions of people using
something that you start getting the
whole developer Community really
starting to experiment and build stuff
because now they're going to be people
who actually use it
um
so I think we'll get you know we got
some of that flywheel going with Quest
Pro but I think it'll really get
accelerated once Quest 3 gets out there
so yeah I'm I'm pretty excited about
this one plus there's hand tracking
without so you don't need to have a
control so this count the cameras aren't
interested in the pass-through
uh of the entire physical reality around
you is also tracking the details of your
hands in order to use that for like
gesture recognition this kind of stuff
yeah we've been able to get way further
on hand recognition in a shorter period
of time than I expected so that's been
pretty cool I don't know did you see the
the demo experience that we built around
um piano like yeah the piano learning to
play piano yeah it's incredible you're
basically playing piano on a table and
it's that's without any controller and
like how well it matches physical
reality with no latency and it's not
it's tracking your hands with no latency
and it's tracking all the people around
you with no latency integrating physical
reality and digital reality
obviously that connects exactly to this
Kodak Avatar which is in parallel allows
us to have ultra realistic
copies of ourselves in this mixed
reality
it's uh so like it's all converging
towards like an incredible digital
experience in the metaverse to me
obviously I love the intimacy of
conversation so even this is awesome but
do you have other
ideas of what this unlocks of like
something like Kodak Avatar unlocks in
terms of applications in terms of uh
things we're able to do
well there's what you can do with
avatars overall in terms of
superimposing digital objects on the
physical world
um and then there's kind of
psychologically what is having
photorealistic do
um you know so
I think we're moving towards a world
where
you know we're going to have something
that looks like normal glasses where you
can just see you see the physical world
but you also see Holograms and in that
world I think that
they're going to be you know not too far
off you know maybe you know by the end
of this decade we'll be living in a
world where there are kind of as many
Holograms when you walk into a room as
there are physical objects and it really
raises this interesting question about
what our
um about you know a lot of people have
this phrase where they they call the
physical world the real world and you
know I kind of think increasingly in the
physical world is super important but I
actually think the real world is the
combination of the physical world and
the digital worlds coming together but
until this technology
they were sort of separate right it's
like you access the digital world
through a screen right and you know
maybe it's a small screen that you carry
around or it's a bigger screen when you
sit down at your desk and strap in for a
long session but
um but they're kind of fundamentally
divorced and disconnected and I think
part of what this technology is going to
do is bring those together into a single
coherent experience of what the modern
real world is which is it's got to be
physical because that we're physical
beings so the physical world is is
always going to be super important but
but increasingly I think a lot of the
things that we kind of think of
um can be digital Holograms I mean any
screen that you have can be a hologram
um you know any media in any book art
um you know it can basically be just as
effective as a hologram as a physical
object any game they were playing a
board game or
um or any kind of physical game cards
um you know ping pong things like that
they're they're often a lot better as
Holograms because you could just kind of
snap your fingers and them and have them
um
show up you know it's like you have a
ping pong table show up in your living
room but then you can snap your fingers
and have it be gone
um so that's super powerful
um so I think that it's actually an
amazing thought experiment of like
how many physical things we have today
that could actually be better as
interactive Holograms
beyond that I think the the most
important thing obviously is people so
the ability to you know have these mixed
Hangouts whether they're social or
meetings where you know you show up to a
conference room you're wearing glasses
um or a headset in the very near term
but you know hopefully by you know for
the next five years glasses or so and um
and you know you're there physically
some people are there physically
um but other people are just there as
Holograms and it feels like it's them
um who are right there and and also by
the way another thing that I think is
going to be fascinating about being able
to blend together the
digital and physical worlds in this way
is we're also going to be able to embody
um AIS as well so I think you'll also
have meetings in the future where you're
basically you know maybe you're sitting
there physically and then you have you
know a couple of other people who are
there's Holograms and then you have like
Bob the AI who's an engineer on your
team who's helping with things and he
can now be embodied as a
um you know as as a a realistic Avatar
as well and just join the meeting
um in that way so I think that that
that's going to be pretty compelling
um as well so then okay so what can you
do with photorealistic avatars compared
to
um kind of the more expressive ones that
we have today well I think a lot of this
actually comes down to
acceptance of the technology
um and
because all the stuff that we're doing I
mean the the motion of your eyebrows the
motion of your eyes the cheeks and all
of that there's actually no reason why
you couldn't do that on an expressive
Avatar too I mean it wouldn't look
exactly like you but you could make a
cartoon version of yourself and still
have it be almost as expressive but I I
do think that there's this bridge
between
the current state of of most our
interactions in the physical world and
where we're getting in the future with
this kind of hybrid physical and digital
world where I think it's gonna be a lot
easier for people to
kind of take some of these experiences
seriously with the photorealistic
avatars to start and then I'm actually
really curious to see where it goes
longer term I could see a world where
people stick to the photorealistic and
maybe they modify them to make them a
little bit more interesting but maybe
fundamentally we like photorealistic
things
um but I could also see a world that
once people get used to the photo the
photorealistic avatars and they get used
to these experiences that I I actually
think that there could be a world where
people actually prefer
um being able to express themselves in
kind of non you know ways that aren't so
tied to their physical reality and so I
that's one of the things that I'm really
curious about and I don't know in a
bunch of our internal experiments on
this one of the things that
has I thought was psychologically pretty
interesting is people have no issues
blending photorealistic stuff and not so
you know we could have a you know for
this specific scene that we're in now we
we happen to sort of be in a dark room
um I think part of that aesthetic
decision I think was based on the way
you like to do your podcast but we've
we've done experiences like this
um where you have like a cartoony
background but photorealistic people who
you're talking to and
we seem to like people just seem to just
think that that is completely normal
right it doesn't bother you it doesn't
feel like it's weird
um another thing that that we've
experienced with is um is basically you
have a photorealistic avatar that you're
talking to and then right next to them
you have an expressive kind of Cartoon
Avatar and that actually is pretty
normal too right it's it's like it's not
that weird right to to basically being
interacting with with different people
in different modes like that so I'm not
sure I think it'll be an interesting
question to what extent these
photorealistic avatars are like
a key part of just transitioning from
being comfortable in the physical world
to this kind of new modern real world
that that kind of includes both the
digital and physical or if this is like
the long-term way that it stays
um that's that's a I mean I think that
they're going to be useless for both the
expressive and the photorealistic over
time I just don't know what the balance
is going to be yeah it's a really good
interesting philosophical question but
to me in the short term the
photorealistic is amazing to what I
would prefer like you said to work on
but like on a beach with a beer just to
see a buddy of mine remotely on a chair
next to me drinking a beer
I mean that as realistic as possible is
an incredible experience so I don't want
any fake hats on him I don't want any
just chilling with it with a friend
drinking beer looking at the ocean while
not being in the same place together I
mean that yeah that experience is just
it's just it's a fundamentally uh
it's just a high quality experience a
friendship whatever we seek in
friendship it seems to be present there
in the same kind of realism I'm seeing
right now this is this is totally a game
changer so to me this is I can see
myself sticking with this for a long
time